introduction and good morning ladies and
gentlemen and it is a pleasure and an
honor for me to be invited to speak at
your entrepreneurial conference and what
better place to address the topic than
the birthplace of new ventures and
innovative thinking Stanford University
Business School has a long and proud
history the focus here on leadership and
innovation for the 21st century is
really unparalleled and I'm delighted
personally to be here to be able to be
here to share our story with such a
distinguished audience the story of Four
Seasons really began some 50 years ago
but I believe some of the lessons I
learned along the way as we started are
still relevant today in fact as Rob
mentioned I recently chronicled my
experience in a book on four seasons and
I did that because I thought it was
important for the 35,000 plus people in
the company and the thousands more who
will be joining the company as we
continue to grow because I believe if
one could understand how and why we got
to where we are today
it can give them a better sense of how
to deal with the future but the book
also brought what my wife Rosalee called
the unexpected rewards hearing from
friends of long ago and for many people
I didn't know many writing very kind
letters and theirs is one that I'd like
to share with you and mr. Jay Nussbaum
made reference to a quote that Rosalie
wrote in the foreword something I said
many many years ago
that I believe the only thing you can
control is your attitude well when he
read that he sent me a copy of a
memorandum titled attitude and asked did
I write it which I didn't and I had
never seen it before
but I thought it was compelling so I'd
like to share that with you today and
the title is attitude and I'm quoting
now from this memorandum the longer you
live the more you will realize the
impact of attitude on life attitude is
more important than facts it is more
important than the past than education
than money than circumstances than
failures and successes than what other
people think or say or do it is more
important than appearances giftedness or
skills it will make a break a company a
church a home a person the remarkable
thing is we have a choice each and every
day regarding the attitude we will
embrace for that day we cannot change
our past we cannot change the fact that
people will act in a certain way we
cannot change the inevitable the only
thing we can do is play on the one
string we have our attitude life is 10%
what happens to us and 90% how we react
to it
we are in charge of our attitudes so
there you have it it's a matches a
message that I thought you might all
find helpful and I guess the concept is
part of the fabric of my book so I
thought I'd share with you some of the
fundamentals of our story with you today
and I think you will see that the depth
of our service culture
and our commitment to it has seen us
through the good and challenging times
alike even through what we went through
this last 2009 our story begins on
Jarvis Street in Toronto where the first
four seasons opened 49 years ago and I
can assure you I never thought at the
time that four seasons would become what
it represents today in fact I can share
with you
in all candor there was no vision
there was no grand dream but throughout
of all four seasons history there has
been a consistent thread and that is
what I'd like to tell you about today
it's the oldest part of our story and
it's what propels us forward as we
continue to grow globally increasingly I
think it is something that matters
greatly to every organization now it may
seem obvious that in the hotel business
our objective is to provide great
service the trick is pulling it off
successfully and that requires an
enormous commitment as our experience
will show because in today's business
environment it's simply not good enough
to rely on the strength of the product
alone international rivalry will make
product quality a given and as products
mature technology begins and brings
parity so why do so many companies who
won't spend what it takes to keep their
customers spend five times as much to
try to get a new one at four seasons
we've always believed that if we give
our customers value our customers will
give us a profit and that has been
proven over a very long period of time
but for the the essential question for
us in the early days was what did our
customers value most market research
said it was luxury and luxury didn't
necessarily mean elegant surroundings
and gourmet me
when we look closely it became clear
that the greatest luxury for our
customers was time and service could
help them make the most of that giving
them greater productivity greater
enjoyment and for us and for our
customers a memorable experience of
course designing service to help busy
people make the most of their precious
time can be challenging
we can't pre-check service or sample it
production and consumption are
simultaneous those few moments of
service delivery our company's
make-or-break point when reputation is
either confirmed or denied and the
outcome in our industry normally depends
on the frontline employees doorman
bellman waiters maids the lowest paid
people and often in too many companies
the least motivated these frontline
staff represent our product to our
customers in the most realistic sense
they are the product it's personal
component so to win or even survive in
the coming service battles customer
satisfaction must be everybody's
business to be at the top of our game at
Four Seasons we have to get service
standards down to the bottom of the
pyramid by far the hardest job in
everyday management and that process
begins with us with our hiring policy
most organizations hire for experience
and the company image how does the
individual fit with the company image we
hire for attitude we want people who
like other people and are therefore more
motivated to serve them competence we
can teach attitude is ingrained when we
open the four seasons in New York we met
more than 15,000 applicants for 400 jobs
we interview the top prosper
four or five times and the last time was
with the general manager of the hotel a
rigorous highly selective expensive
procedure but mine are compared with the
cost of struggling for years to change
habits that come with ingrained poor
attitudes new surveys now show that most
managers in North America believe what
employees want most is job security and
competitive pay but job security today
especially is too very tentative to say
the least
and while salary is certainly a
consideration other things matter much
more and polls taken recently for
fortunes annual listing as Rob mentioned
and the hundred best companies to work
for which I'm happy to say has always
included us since it started find that
employees in these firms value primarily
three things first to work for leaders
who inspire their best second a physical
environment that makes work enjoyable
and third and I think most important a
sense of purpose and a feeling that
working for more than a paycheck that
they're helping to build a company that
they can take pride in in short some
daily meaning along with their daily
bread great companies are like armies
which fight for a common purpose
creating a sense of unity and belonging
that really does breed teamwork we may
live in a work world of reason
intensified by technology but every
customer perception every employee
response is governed by feelings and
beliefs and when employees feel their
future is linked to that of a company
whose values they share it inspires
commitment to that company's success in
every area we push down responsibility
from head office to our frontline people
who have the authority to make most
decisions that
they feel are needed to satisfy our
guests we treat them as members of an
elite team but we set very challenging
goals and that's why early on we set a
mandate of zero mistakes inevitably of
course mistakes occur that's natural but
when our employees are trusted to use
their common sense they can and deuteron
mishaps into new service opportunities
then what the customer remembers is not
the complaint but the outcome in our
experience and this goes over many many
years
performance rises to meet expectations
the resultant customer satisfaction
boosts employee confidence and
self-esteem and living up to that
growing self-image keeps raising
performance levels this requires
managers who are less bosses than
mentors and communicators whose role is
to bring out each individual's best and
weld them into a winning team by being
upfront and open letting people know how
they're doing and buying being
accessible and visible and communication
is crucial for employees to act on their
own initiative they have to know our
priorities and we have to know what our
customers are saying to them we have to
recognize their contributions and listen
to them consistently at four seasons we
pay as much attention to employee
complaints as to guest complaints we
upgrade employee facilities whenever we
upgrade a hotel disallow class
distinction and cafeterias and parking
lots established career paths and
promotion from within and we augment the
physical atmosphere with a wide range of
benefits as one employee put it I think
a little exuberant league
grape a great perks great food I'm
treated like a five diamond hotel guest
from the beginning we've always had an
implicit
operating philosophy so some 30 years
ago as we expanded I decided to make it
explicitly so I sat down with our
director of communications and detailed
a formal credo based on the golden rule
the cornerstone of what would later be
called our corporate culture in essence
in essence to treat others all others
customers employees partners suppliers
as we would want to be treated there was
nothing new about this this is a
standard statement many people would use
even back then such credos were common
though seldom believed what was new who
was that we enforced it senior managers
who couldn't or wouldn't walk the talk
were all went about within a few years
it was a painful process and personally
distressing and perhaps the hardest
thing I ever had to do but the fastest
way for management to destroy its
credibility is to say employees come
first and to be seen putting them last
better not to profess any values than
not to live up to them now conceiving a
vision and a strategy is relatively easy
the hard part is selling it getting it
across to all levels of employees and
that became my task preaching the gospel
of service every day on every trip to
every hotel continuously restating it
developing it focusing employees at
every level on one priority giving
customers added value through service
and that's the way it has to be as
managers we all live in a glass house
every action every action watched and
discussed on the company grapevine if
we're seen showing greater concern for
power prestige and costs than for the
customer and the values we profess then
we forfeit beliefs
and trust along with our goal of trying
to be the best trust Trust is the unseen
and often - and too often neglected
determinant of corporate success it has
never been more important a more
important consideration than it is today
it's the emotional capital of leadership
building community spirit certifying
communication and fostering teamwork
it's the essence of a brand name and a
synonym for customer loyalty we've yet
to go into a location and we're now in
more than 30 countries where upholding
the golden rule hasn't brought workers
on-site we have found exceptional
workers in Eastern Europe and the
Caribbean in the heart of New York City
and in the pineapple fields of rural
Hawaii in Maui for example those workers
made four seasons number one in the
island after its first year of opening
and every year our service culture grows
stronger we see the effects every day in
each hotel employees develop a
camaraderie that deepens creating a
sense of community that makes
cooperation the norm this was
illustrated more profoundly than any of
us could have imagined during the
tsunami in Southeast Asia with a wave
approached and struck at our hotel in
the Maldives each employee acted
intuitively to ensure the comfort and
safety of our guests they did everything
they could think of to ease minds and
calm nerves some were even credited with
saving lives within 24 hours they
evacuated the island and chartered a
plane that flew every guest to safety
following that tsunami there was an
outpouring of gratitude from guests who
had been saved and one wrote and I'd
like to quote that letter to you
let me stress that your groups strength
rests on rock made up of the local
employees who while having been selected
for doing their job well have shown in a
time of utmost crises a level of
dedication that no training and no
amount of money can never generate
clearly our employees action that day
touched our guests in ways they will
never forget what they accomplished in
the midst of adversity may sound
extraordinary but I suspect any of our
employees around the world would act
with the same dignity and grace they're
motivated by an inner need to do well by
others our people to light and surprise
our guests every day the sum of their
efforts is what makes Four Seasons
unique so by nurturing the full
potential of every employee from top to
bottom in any company I believe that
businesses can tap the most important
resource for success for the 21st
century it's something to think about as
each of you look to the future and
pursue new ventures or strengthen the
ones you've already established thank
you once again for including me in your
conference I wish you continued success
and a bright outlook for the future
thank
we're now going to open up to questions
now I'd like for you if you don't mind
to repeat the question because we don't
have microphones in the credit thank you
I'm embarrassed to read the question to
you because he's complimenting me he's
asking being charismatic and such how
are people are able to follow in terms
of your what you've done we should all
only try to do what we can do best and
you know my skill set allowed me to
become what I am and clearly as my role
in the company I've always had to
prepare for the natural evolution of
seniority in the company and we've
always been able to promote from within
so every senior leadership position in
this company has changed over the last
many years all from within and they've
carried on and we call it a seamless
transition they all come with different
skills and I believe and you know
history will prove that leadership is
situational skills needed for one time
in terms of the issues that a company
might be facing might be very different
than other times
so as four seasons has now evolved the
strategy for the company is set we all
know what we're doing and where we
should how we can get to the next stage
and that was based upon what we refer to
now as the four pillars in
reconstructing the company there were
four key strategic decisions that we've
identified and they are based upon
quality service culture and brand and
the strategy going forward is to
continue to reinforce those four pillars
so there is no longer a need for
say a vision there's a need for
execution for competence in being able
to how do you administer the company as
it's getting bigger how do you become
more efficient more effective so the
people who are presently in the position
to keep moving up the ladder and to take
over my role are clearly skilled at
being able to do that and they've grown
up with the company over the last 20 25
years so they intuitively know and
understand it does not mean need
somebody like me to continue running the
company it needs people who have an
understanding of how we that's why I
said in the book why I did it
is to give an understanding of how we
got to where we are and if to start
something is much more difficult so to
keep it going becomes just hey we know
what got us where we are let's not lose
sight of it so the best example I can
use when I say leadership is situational
and you're too young to go back this far
but in World War two Winston Churchill
took England out of the depths of what
was a frightening war and led the
country to success great charismatic
leader in the United States after
President Roosevelt died Harry Truman
took over a man of great competence who
could take chaos and turn it into an
organization so they could move forward
to very different leaders but the times
dictate what's required so I believe in
four seasons we have prepared for the
continual evolution and what will be a
seamless transition yes if something
happened to me there might be a shot
what's good you know hit by a bus etc I
should change that my wife heard me say
that one thing is just look get a little
more romantic make it make it a Mack
truck or something
but I believe there might be shock for
the first three to six months and after
that everybody in the company would be
digging deep to make sure they showed
that this company's got strength to go
forward so we shouldn't look to copy we
should look to apply our skills and if
you will all learn your role and senior
leadership is to prepare for those
people who should be following and
that's really what I've been able to do
and it's worked out quite well the
question was that your group here is
looking as venture capitalist and how do
you take companies public well at the
end of the question was we've gone
private and how do we think about that
the idea of going private was not my
idea and it wasn't done for any
financial reasons it came as a proposal
that looked interesting after we sort of
dissected a bit that there wouldn't be
any real change because I wasn't looking
for a change in my lifestyle in terms of
my work load what appealed to me as I
controlled the company is that here was
an opportunity where I could control the
change of ownership in two hands that I
thought would preserve and continue the
legacy of four seasons because as I say
if something happened to me under my
control my family would have to sell and
that could be a jump ball and highest
bidder might be able to buy the company
so this was an unusual opportunity where
the type of investors we were talking to
really were not investing as venture
capitalists might do to buy and sell
these were people who could afford to
own long term and that was the key was
this intended to be a long-term
commitment and clearly as the people you
know Prince will lead and cascade
this company these are long-term players
so for the company and everybody in the
company when you asked about the
leadership and the their future relies
upon the stability of the company and
our ability to continue in the path
that's being set it gives everybody in
the company not just a degree of comfort
but an ability to look at their future
understand their position in the company
and realize that there will be no change
that will upset them so it really
establishes a very strong foundation for
the company to continue on the path that
it is set for themselves so it's worked
out from the individuals in the company
for myself etc to everybody's
satisfaction yes ma'am
the question is when did the idea of
Four Seasons come to be a vision well as
I say I didn't know much about the hotel
business so my role into it was not to
go into the hotel business it was a
real-estate play just building it and
see what happens so I'm still a builder
by trade and construction was my
background but after we had built the
third hotel and that was 1970 when we
opened the Inn on the park in London and
I had put together the business deal
that we were involved with conglomerate
at that time ITT to build in partnership
a major convention hotel in downtown
Toronto and the contrast of how that
hotel ran which was very successful as a
convention hotel and what we had done in
London England gave me a look into the
industry that appealed to me and that I
thought we might do something special
which was in London this was our third
hotel we opened and we're competing
against what today and then were the
best hotels in the world you've heard
the names the foyer the Savoy Claridge's
cannot Ritz these were the grand hotels
of the era and we're up against them in
terms of competing for the business well
in the first year of operation we were
awarded the best hotel in Europe and
beat all those players on their home
field so the question was if we could do
that there could we not do it everywhere
so the contrast of what we were doing
there this was a small boutique geared
to the personal service of treating
every customer who came through the
front door as a guest not deciding who
should be our customers compared to the
convention hotel that was very
successful
dealing in a different type of market
that gave me the idea which developed to
be the very first key strategic decision
that I mentioned before that we decided
then to only operate medium-sized hotels
of exceptional quality and to try to be
the best so that is where you might say
the vision started but that's a far cry
you know people looked at it and they
said well you know you want to only
operate one type of Hotel that's no big
deal but to say we're going to be the
best that was a stretch now I didn't say
we were the best that was setting an
objective that every Hotel we opened
could we follow the format that allowed
us to compete against the best and be a
winner and that's what we did so that
was the beginning you might say of
division yes sir
yeah as I mentioned we base the
philosophy and the principles of the
company on that one simple profound
statement of what the golden rule
represents in our language that simply
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you but if you look at history you
will see that that statement the golden
rule is part of every religious belief
every religion in the world in their
scriptures recite that principle
different ways but meaning exactly the
same so as a company we as I say higher
looking for people who have a similar
work ethic and a value system and that
is where this principle of attitude
there isn't any country city in the
world that we couldn't go into and pull
together a core of people from that
community who believe in that principle
it's being proven over and over again
it's the way most of you had been
brought up it's the way when you go out
in the world and get married the way
you're going to want to bring your
children up and that brings diversity of
different cultures people background
beliefs but with one common value system
and that is the tie that binds this
company together it was a theory I put
out a long time ago when we when I said
before you know we're gonna try to be
the best and they said what do you mean
how you gonna do that and I said we're
going to try to make the quality of our
service our competitive advantage we're
gonna do it in a way cuz that's how we
became and how we beat the other people
in London it wasn't a grand building it
wasn't having any difference it was that
we dealt with service
as a very precious thing so we're saying
we're gonna make the quality of our
service our competitive advantage that's
what's going to define us and
distinguish us from our competitors
well if that's what we're going to do
who's going to do it it's going to be
the people people who work in the hotel
it's on their shoulders so we had to
give them what they needed and what they
wanted in order for them to perform at
this level and that's what the culture
did the culture said could we could we
create a highly qualified competent
workforce based on an ethical credo
could we well in practice over many many
years the kids who join the company
early and that was their work ethic have
proven that that theory is now a fact
there is absolutely no doubt about it
for anybody in this company who
recognizes and believes in you know so
the base is there the momentum is there
and as we are growing worldwide we can
go anywhere and we'll bring together a
core people let me just to emphasize
that point we opened a hotel in Istanbul
some years ago but here after I was
having dinner with one of the owners and
his wife and she asked me where do you
get these people from and I said what
people he said there are the people who
work in the hotel where do they come
from
and I said well I guess you know the
local community or the villages
surrounding the city she's no no no
these are not Turkish people I said what
do you mean said I have Turkish people
working for me and these are not Turkish
people that was with the general mass of
Marcus where do you get him from he said
of course they are it's the same people
it's how you treat them give them the
respect the dignity they're entitled to
an opportunity just an opportunity for
people in that part of the world is
enormous
we're fortunate to be born a part of the
world we all have opportunity but going
to those other countries that live under
depressed states it's not as easy so
there isn't any doubt in any person who
works in four seasons that the ability
of giving people an opportunity they
will rise to the occasion take on that
challenge so the question was as we
started going down the road to growth
what was going to be the problem could
we continue on what we set out to be the
best what were the bumps along the road
that we might face good question and
that question kept coming up so after we
had five hotels I would get from the
company we hold staff you know town hall
meetings and they say how many more
hotels can you build and operate with
this fanatical attention to every detail
and every customers needs and I said I
don't know but if the last hotel we open
and operate doesn't embody everything
we've learned and we should be better if
we've done that and we can't say we are
I said that'll be it because I wasn't
interested I'm not didn't have the
skills or anything to start build a big
company I was interested in building a
good company well that question kept
coming up five ten fifteen hotels I gave
the same answer because I did not know
was size going to be you know our
Waterloo well after that I stopped
saying it because I I thought you could
see size had nothing to do with it it
was just a question could we continue to
do it the same way would we lose sight
of what it was that made us successful
so we centered on and focused on stick
with a game plan don't look for new
ideas but if we continue to grow as we
have that will be the way we'll become
the best company because what we were
really saying is that it wasn't a
corporate organization that was doing
this
it was each hotel we put the mandate out
it's in your hands you're the ones there
who are dealing with the customers day
in and day out and we rely upon you so
it was the general manager and his
senior people who had to instill in the
people what was required of them and to
manage them in a way that made each
hotel the best that's exactly the plan
as we just opened in Beirut that we are
using today but now we have a company
that can help each hotel much more than
we had back then so we are able to build
the company and to grow and get the
reputation we've got with the experience
we've got now the support we've got now
the bench strength of people and a brand
name clearly we should be able to
continue to make each hotel as it opens
to be the best of that city so that's
was the threat could we we didn't know
and in practice we've proved it's not
sighs it's getting and bringing together
that diversity of people who have
similar work ethics yes sir
you mean maybe partners or suppliers
well you do run into difficulties
there's no question about that business
is never smooth Road you address those
problems when they occur and continue
dealing with them you just don't lower
your standards well we can't we try to
join for the question was how do we
control other companies or other people
from not acting in a way which would be
consistent with what we believe usually
in your making a business deal what you
want to do is make sure you're dealing
with somebody your partner that you have
a degree of compatibility with that
you're not joining forces with somebody
who's completely off the radar screen in
terms of what you believe in how you act
but you do run into the problems and
you've managed to get through those and
they're not always successful but you
learn by those experiences and we've had
you know some mishaps along the way you
know thought we had a good deal didn't
work out lost a hotel you know lost a
lot of money in the process it was a
country that we couldn't do anything
about the laws there were very different
than what we believe so you gain
experience try not to make the same
mistake the second or third time so as a
company we've run into our share of
problems clearly we've been able to
overcome them otherwise we wouldn't
continue to be successful but today we
have you know in spite of the economy
and what's happened in part of 208 in
our pipeline of development we penciled
more deals in the last two years than we
ever had before so presently as a
company we have over 50 hotels that are
under one form of development or another
so as a company we will become a hundred
and fifty or eighty three hotels now
will become a hundred and fifty
tells over the next eight to ten years
so it's a robust industry and we're
going to continue to stay focus at that
one end of it yes sir
that wasn't a question was a compliment
so so I thank you and that does happen
because people and see maybe there's
another way that we can improve our
business what we're doing every business
every business or going into whether
it's you know hedge funds or dealing
with your own company people people are
the reason a company succeeds that's why
I said it's a resource that is often
overlooked but if you deal with people
in your company or in your control you
no matter which gets them all working in
the same direction rolling the people
power is remarkable
yes No
the question was that where was their
different styles of leadership that I
deployed I guess are employed as you're
starting a company do you change I don't
think so I'm sure when I was younger I
might have been presenting different
ways because I was probably selling
without much experience obviously but I
don't think you change as a person I
think you should deal with your skills
and don't try to become something that
you might not be I think you each all
have a skill set we all have weaknesses
and we tried to you know conceal the
weaknesses and dwell on our strengths
and to bring people together who have
different strengths so together we are
then become more successful so I would
say start small and I was talking to
Jessica here this morning and we talked
about well what drives you follow your
passions don't decide today where you
want to be five years from today pick it
up get started see where it takes you
and just put a hundred percent of your
effort into what you're going to do
don't use the word if if I tried harder
I would have succeeded if this didn't
happen
go for it accept the realities if you're
running a race and you came in last but
you ran your heart out you know what hey
I gave it my all I know where I stand so
that's all you got to worry about and
not try to sort of manipulate who you
are but you know you've all got
abilities you wouldn't be sitting you
wouldn't be in at school if you didn't
have the skillset and abilities to
continue growing I'm saying this morning
to Robin you know judge yourself based
upon what you've already succeeded with
you've accomplished more
in your life now than most people ever
do because you've been able to apply to
a very prominent school and be accepted
so clearly you've got the ability to be
able to continue growing and that's
usually what your future will be a
reflection of what you've already
achieved at the years you've had to
compete against others and arrive at
this very very prominent school okay
the question is if we are so certain of
our strategy and direction and we
confine others how do we give other
people an opportunity to participate in
an innovative creative way if you're
hiring very talented people because they
as he said we're all ambitious
well ambition is you know I guess
satisfied in many different ways is it
all of a sudden being a superstar to be
able to say look this is what I did for
the company or is it taking on a
responsibility in the company when I say
taking it on I mean hey it's on your
shoulders so we all have
responsibilities that we're gonna be
accountable for and growing and making
that better than it was when you
inherited it so it doesn't necessarily
have to be of identifying something in
the company that makes you sort of
become prominent it's being able to work
as a team member to be able to be part
of a team that moves the company forward
and recognize and feel in that capacity
you have been properly rewarded
personally meaningful so as I mentioned
before we couldn't possibly keep people
in the company if they weren't achieving
their ambitions and the success of four
seasons has been that people have joined
the company and have continued to stay
with this company from I think the
average average length of years of the
top hundred and fifty senior people in
the company is over 17 years
all of these people are on every
headhunters list they've all have the
opportunity to go and look at further
fields they stay by choice that's the
only way a company can succeed is the
people this serves their purpose and
being able to participate and contribute
in a meaningful way we for seasons do
not own any hard assets we don't have a
building that we could splints you know
siphon off and sell off parts of the
company to make some money so the
investors who paid a high price of well
over 3.8 billion have bought into a
company that its assets are its
intellectual capital the people who
continue to make the company a success
and those people are very highly
qualified so clearly they have satisfied
their ambitions do all of them do that
have we lost some of course so I think
every company has to give and make sure
they are giving people the the space
they need to feel that they are in a
role whether it's working for a company
or working on their own they're getting
the degree of satisfaction Sandee